super productive day so far as we're
about to work out and start this
business Sunday I just had to Xander
call me the worst human on earth nope
because I beat them five nothing in
basketball macro my mom doesn't come
around like a visible I see with clarity
hi my name is Gabby
Tom but I've been telling you
accountability I'm triple-a given a
pedigree second being in a special
offensive piece putting the work that
I'm doing are the moving furniture
Travis all right
that Sunday continues last week was
super successful let's start with a
recap Vader sports exploded tons of
stuff on on Vader sports a lot of stuff
for our athletes I appreciate it a lot
of good stuff for the brands that we
tell to us got some good sponsorship
opportunities some good exposure coming
their way
and so that was super exciting the
beanie stuff tons of beanie stuff I've
got to figure that out almost too much
beings that we hadn't started that and
got a little bit of a list of stuff for
you guys this week there's going to come
like a really fun series just a great
way for us to do business got a small
startup that wanted to do a sponsorship
thing but now wants to get a piece of a
business so they're flying in from
Middle America to see AJ and I so it's a
pretty cool so far yeah so far so good
all right first in step Sunday they saw
this week is people with seven-figure
businesses selling a physical product
that isn't a
that is a supplement or think thing that
means your so if you get our seven
figure business I'm looking for direct
to consumer business development for
seven senior businesses selling actual
products where I can build the help
build on the brand so I was this dead
last week was hey we got to we got to a
million dollars selling you know our our
exercise ball or or our belt or our
iPhone case but we don't be reading
negative 1/8 bigger level a lot of
people offering equity may be saying
leave this one company that I shouldn't
get me move you to New York sit right
next to my team and see if the stuff
that we do can take it to from 1 million
to 10 million in sales you know you guys
know me follow me none of these sleeves
of thing are you know I want it to be
very clean direct consumer product so if
you got that then you feel like you've
tapped out with you know meals harder
the you hit a certain level and you want
to take to the next level those Wine
Library data video where the company has
exploded and how to do that so can you
have a Matt big one will you pick one of
these deletion timer mine okay um next
business under community Timmy up if you
get an average of fifteen hundred likes
proposed under Instagram hit it up so
the female 1500 plus Instagram in the
title 1500 plus in the grip Instagram
likes on average not one time you got
lucky that's your average look into some
stuff with the guarantee shop hit me up
I'm just holding them
a podcast getting serious about McGarry
the experience number one for this dev
summit please subscribe to my podcasts
listen to it a lot of you do this in the
morning
you know you can listen to it a lot of
you do this in the morning you listen to
it like water walking work
you can listen to it podcast check it
putting out a lot of good stuff there
the full Daymond John fireside chat one
on the podcast first I'm a big fan of
Jab Jab Jab right hook I was able to
duck right hook right hook right hook
right hook and so I think the biggest
way for me to do things is what I feel
like there's value in return still not
out on video so for example that anyway
here's the business Sunday opportunity
podcast blowing up podcast blowing up
sit down there Tyler I know d-roc you
know do these more utilitarian go to the
fancy episode podcast blow up looking
for my podcast to get more exposure if
you've got a cool way so many you guys I
don't like [ __ ] shortcut [ __ ]
anyway you know if you write podcast
reviews if you're journalists if it's
got a way to defend my podcast and look
at the more exposure for more listeners
not looking for any shortcuts no
algorithms cleaning a hard work sweat
like I'm putting in here but a exposure
on the left podcast blow up you can do
some good stuff with my pockets put in
email is me okay breaking news in this
episode you just have to repeat it good
so fast all right that's one of the best
teachers advice I ever got from Gary and
social media comments and people are
commenting and this is recent this is
very recent if people are putting if
you're putting out content and people
are commenting being [ __ ] whatever
it is the Maya sit shift was instead of
being mad instead of like arguing with
them instead of being a dick back feel
bad for them but feel sorry that they're
there sitting at the computer like
typing mean comments like while you're
there putting out good content that for
me was one of the biggest and you might
not be putting out good content you
think you can convict it's really good
why not they may be right
my whole point is I just feel bad for
somebody who's got so much pain inside
that they need to tear other people down
I just do I just genuinely do and
especially it's easy for me because I
know how this ends up right like like if
they're right like there's places to be
cynical there's things to be observant
about there I don't think like people
should blindly whatever but if you've
got that much pain in you you know like
for me I always feel bad for my
commenters because they're going to lose
historically the filming says that
Sunday when a commercial breaks from
Jordan that's it
so good business Sunday several things
for you guys to attack
Tyler do a little condensed version of
last week this tough Sunday for
everybody missed it and they're right
here with that but for everybody else
you can move on with their day I've got
a huge Monday coming up so you get a
bunch of good content for next daily be
gay rock amazing job on that Canada
episode I thought that was an
unbelievable fire one of my favorite
episodes cases appearance probably a
push your game up be rocket like the
Million Dollar Man says
everybody's got a price bizdev Sunday's
banner sports if you are a start-up
brand is bad
small blends with myopically athletes
and stickers and posters I want for a TV
company I'm looking for somebody who is
really great at sourcing high quality
materials kleban in the YouTube section
your favorite one-minute clip will use
the community to decide which clips we
should be making in our one-minute
Instagram Facebook and Twitter videos
[Music]